a 2d creature could be living on the
surface of a sphere and not know it to
them space would still feel flat and
two-dimensional same if they were living
on the surface of a pringle a clever
flatl could investigate by drawing
triangles on flat space the angles of a
triangle will add up to 180 but on the
surface of a sphere they will add up to
more than this and on a pringle will add
up to less if a 2d creature could be
living on the surface of a 3D shape then
could we 3D creatures be living on the
surface of a 4D shape could our space be
the surface of a 4D hypersphere or a
hyper Pringle or is our universe flat
scientists have investigated this by
drawing big triangles in space they've
also added up all the mass and energy in
the universe to get a density and used
that to try to discern the shape and all
these efforts so far Point towards our
universe being flat or at least the part
of it that we can observe